let's start today with inflation now i i
want to approach this from an economic
perspective because i've been getting
dozens of emails from people
wanting an explanation about how
inflation eventually goes away and i've
touched on this a little bit but let's
talk about it in more detail now when i
say i don't want to make this a
political story
there are some political statements i
have to make because there is so much
political misinformation around
inflation there has been inflation high
inflation all over the world some
countries with higher inflation than the
united states some countries with lower
inflation than the united states there
are many in the u.s who want to blame
joe biden for inflation i have found no
evidence that joe biden is to blame and
in fact
the u.s is not at the highest or at the
lowest level of inflation over the last
year this is a global phenomenon related
to a lot of different things that we've
talked about and for those pointing
specifically to joe biden's covid uh
relief package as the reason for the
inflation
remember that donald trump did two such
packages and they were bigger than joe
biden so if that's why you blame biden
you have to blame trump at least two
times as much and none of these people
are so like with the political stuff out
of the way there's lots of confusion
about like how does inflation eventually
go away and
one of the realities about inflation is
that sustained inflation will eventually
reduce inflation and i'm going to
explain to you how that works but when
people talk about markets and cycles
this is actually what we mean we one of
the best there are many examples of
markets that don't work or are kind of
pie in the sky fantasy they don't relate
to how the real world works when it
comes to inflation
ultimately resolving inflation it
actually does work this way so to start
this
let's talk about what is a good level of
inflation or deflation or no price
changes like what would we want
well a really high level of inflation is
bad because people very quickly can't
afford things it's bad for the economy
because things get so expensive that
others don't buy anything so it's bad
for business
it makes it so that people's wages no
longer can keep up with the cost of
living so really high inflation is bad
and we're seeing high inflation at least
by american historical standards right
now
it might seem like well then is
deflation good because if prices go down
people can afford stuff no deflation is
also bad and again the framework here is
uh
the framework is the traditional
understanding of how modern economies
work you could say david sir
the entire framework is crap put it in
the trash and that's a different
discussion but at least in the modern
economic framework
deflation is bad because if you expect
things to get cheaper in the future
you would wait to buy them i mean okay
things you absolutely need you're not
going to say well i won't eat for a
month because food will be cheaper in a
month no then you're dead you need food
but with a ton of different purchases
if you expect prices to be lower in the
future because we are in the middle of a
deflationary situation
you would say i'm going to wait to buy
stuff and when you don't buy businesses
don't have money coming in meaning they
have to lay off workers and now those
workers don't have money to buy things
because they've been laid off so that's
a deflationary spiral that's also bad so
in traditional economics the
understanding is you want a little bit
of inflation a little bit of inflation
is where economic growth comes from
a little bit of inflation is the reason
why people would you're not going to go
hoarding supplies
but you would purchase things if i want
to look at a car
and the car is affordable today the car
is 10 grand and i can afford 10 grand if
i expect the car will be 8 grand next
year i wait i don't buy it if the if the
car is already unaffordable i don't buy
it but if the car is 10 grand today and
i expect it to be 10 500 in a year
that's a pretty good reason to go and
buy the car today so i'm now supporting
the dealership i'm supporting the
manufacturer okay so that's the
framework for why we say a little bit of
inflation is good
um
let's talk about then what happens when
there is inflation
inflation initially creates more
inflation people fear wow prices are
going up they might go even higher i've
got to go and buy stuff now before i can
no longer afford it
that increases inflation even more
and things start to cost more for
workers so the workers demand more wages
and to cover the increased wages the
employers start charging more for the
products and you have an inflationary
cycle
this only works in the short term
because you can only pre-purchase so
much stuff you can only get ahead
before prices go up so long eventually
inflation is going to reduce the
purchasing power for people people
aren't going to be able to buy as much
stuff a great example is like with a
house if you've got a down payment saved
up and you can afford a thousand dollar
a month mortgage
at a three percent mortgage maybe your
house that you can afford is 200 grand
when mortgage rates go up as we see
inflation
you can no longer afford a 200 000 house
because to keep your payment at a
thousand bucks because of the higher
rate now you can only afford a hundred
and eighty thousand dollar house this
then puts pressure on the home seller to
decrease the price so eventually
inflation which takes away purchasing
power starts to make a downward pressure
on prices and that ultimately is what
reduces the inflation now obviously
there's problems with doing nothing
because
in the short and medium term while this
is going on
people start to be unable to afford
things that they need poor people are
hurt the most by this inflationary cycle
so you've got to figure out how do we
deal with that and there's a whole bun
that's beyond the scope of this segment
but there's a whole bunch of things that
governments can do to say well let's
let's figure out how to support uh folks
who can't afford certain necessities
during this period of time
high inflation can hurt business
innovation because it starts to get more
expensive to start a business someone
might say i'm not going to start the
business well it's a business that could
have employed people it's a business
that could have manufactured a product
or provided a service so that's not good
for the economy either and you've got to
figure out how to deal with that
none of this is to pretend that anything
is any worse or better than it actually
is it's to gain an understanding of how
longer term
inflation will reduce inflation in the
meantime
we have to take very seriously the
effect that it has on people the effect
that it has on the economy but for
people who say well what can't joe biden
just like sign something and fix this
issue
in an economy the size of the economy of
the united states
no the answer is no
and um the mechanism that will
ultimately reduce that inflation to some
degree
is inflation itself let me know if
that's clear or if it's not clear
we have been seeing mass shooting after
mass shooting after mass shooting make
national headlines recently and we have
polling that suggests to us hey you know
what americans really are hungry for
some gun safety regulations they they
want them and there is a very
interesting a poll from pew research
compiled by vox and we're going to put a
vox graphic up on the screen and when
you look nationally
yes led by democrats but republicans
also
we see greater than 85 percent support
for some mental health restrictions on
who can own firearms we see more than 80
support for background checks what we
would call universal background checks
meaning there is no situation where a
gun is sold that would be exempt from a
background check we see about 78 percent
of the country against open carry
without a permit there are some states
where you can open carry with no permit
and even the less popular stuff like
banning assault style weapons or banning
high-capacity magazines even those
provisions have close to two-thirds
support right around 65 percent
so very clearly republicans have seen
the polling republicans are now
understanding hey a lot of these things
are popular with americans
we as republicans can't just be the
party of saying do nothing arm teachers
and eliminate doors or whatever they've
been talking about so now mitch
mcconnell and some other republicans are
saying you know we are we are okay we're
supportive
of the framework that's been established
for this senate gun safety deal so we're
going to look at a clip but i have to
tell you
i am so skeptical of everything that's
going on here on both sides and i'll
explain all of that in a moment but
here's mitch mcconnell yesterday making
headlines wow republicans being
reasonable they support
wait do they support the bill or they do
they support the framework well that's a
key distinction take a listen to this
senate cornin who as you know i asked to
be the point person on our side to see
if we could
come to a an outcome
after these horrible school shootings
and his
teammates
indicated as you have reported
coming together but kind of behind a
framework
which hopefully can be turned into
legislative language
and past
for myself i'm comfortable with the
firmwork and if the legislation ends up
reflecting
what
the framework
indicates
i'll be
supportive
right
so a number
of ifs in there right i'm supportive of
the framework
which
hopefully will get us to a bill and if
the legislation reflects what's in the
framework then it is hopefully something
that we can support
now there's two sides to this this is a
great opportunity for republicans to say
this and then oppose it either because
while the legislation ended up being
different than the framework or were
disappointed in what democrats
ultimately put here uh but there's
another aspect to this which is the bill
itself
is pretty damn crappy now i don't want
to just
listen i i am not i am okay with
incremental change and taking steps in
the right direction and if this is all
that can be passed well we've got to
pass it i'm going to tell you what's in
this framework
but it is pretty damn weak very very
weak um there are a few different things
here so first of all there are red flag
provisions that um
are in the framework meaning that you
have a process
that will allow you to do sort of some
kind of of um
for those individuals who are believed
to have mental health conditions that
should prevent them from having a
firearm this is a framework that would
allow some of those to be established
there are 19 states in washington d.c
that already have some version of that
and that's something that would be in
the bill and listen republicans have
been talking about this is a mental
health issue so that's something they're
generally supportive of although some
republicans are saying you're kind of
eliminating due process
instead of actually saying well
you are now a felon and you can't have a
firearm which would be due process
some republicans are against these red
flag laws saying you're basically just
saying some psychologist can sign off
and then you don't you don't get your
constitutional right to a firearm so
that could be a problem they want a more
rigorous process for background checks
specifically on people between 18 and 21
which would include an enhanced review
where you contact state and local law
enforcement if you have criminal records
it could be disqualifying there's a
proposal
about
who should have to register as a
firearms dealer for the purposes of
conducting background checks there's
some squishiness to that where you can
be a dealer you and i would look at it
and we would say this is a dealer but
they don't currently have to register as
such and thus don't have to
comply with background checks laws there
should be no question of that every sale
should require a background check no
matter where it happens they also want
new penalties on straw purchasing of
firearms to improve the prosecution of
traffickers this is where someone who
can legally get guns buys a bunch of
them and then sells them to people who
cannot legally get guns those are called
straw purchases and then they want money
for mental health services as well so
there's nothing remotely controversial
here in the framework any sane country
would do all of these things and much
more
but that's exactly the problem number
one
the bill is so milk toast that it
doesn't do
almost any of the things that i outlined
in my framework for what should be done
and at the same time republicans still
might not support it so this is yet
again it's a good chance
maybe to show that republicans will
block even the weakest
gun safety provisions
but at the same time maybe republicans
will support it because it does so
little and then they can say look the
democrats put together a bill we
supported it and we still have gun
violence which of course we would have
because this bill has absolutely no
teeth so
it i i hate to say it it all seems like
it's a great setup for the republican
party here's a bonus clip here's mitch
mcconnell being asked why
people who can't legally buy cigarettes
should be able to buy semi-automatic
weapons mitch mcconnell supported
raising the age at which you can buy
tobacco from 18 to 21 and mitch
mcconnell does not answer why should
americans who are 18 years old not be
allowed to buy cigarettes which is
good try
i've already told you my my view not
really a try it's a good question
framework
if it leads
to a piece of legislation
i intend to support it i think it's
progress for the country
and
i think that
the bipartisan group has done the best
they can
to get total support
and the background
check enhancement for that age group i
think is a step in the right direction
yeah it's it's so weak a background
check enhancement just for those 18 to
21. so mitch not falling for any trick
questions like why should you be able to
get an ar-15 but not cigarettes which is
really not a trick question it's a good
question
let me know what you think is the fate
of this bill find me on twitter at d
pacman we'll take a quick break and be
right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right don't worry we're not going to
spend a ton of time on this but i do
want to go over the last sort of 24
hours of reactions from the trump camp
to the january six trump riot committee
hearings we're first going to look at
some of the things that donald trump
posted to his platform truth social
truth essential of course and we're also
going to look at a supposed 12-page
letter that trump wrote well let me say
it a different way it's a 12-page letter
a 12-page letter that trump supposedly
wrote we're going to look at that as
well so let's start with truth essential
or truth social donald trump going
absolutely bonkers on his uh social
media platform about these hearings
starting with quote
word out that the reason the unselects
have canceled wednesday's kangaroo court
is a total lack of interest leading to
very poor television ratings could this
be so maybe they should try getting a
more talented hollywood producer than
the former president of abc fake news he
didn't do so well so this is a um
a calculated uh talking point from
republicans that the nobody cares about
the hearings now of course it's not true
listen it's not the super bowl okay we
all acknowledge that
these are boring hearings by traditional
standards although i've found them quite
riveting myself uh but there were about
22 million people who watched the first
night of broadcast
that doesn't include any of the online
audiences which were which were huge so
the the audience has actually been fine
trump then on truth social saying quote
does anybody notice that the unselect
committee refuses to discuss or debate
in any way shape or form the many
irrefutable types of election fraud and
irregularities found in the 2020
election this is cancel culture because
they know that they have zero chance of
winning that debate so sad to see our
capital seat country falling apart now
the opposite is true in fact
every
single allegation of voter fraud
or irregularities
has been
uh
significantly refuted not only have they
been refuted by republicans in testimony
during the committee hearings including
from william barr and others
every single claim has been investigated
close to 70 such claims were brought to
courts and the courts found that there
was no merit or that there was no
standing i will gladly say some of the
courts took it as a standing issue
allegations of supposed dead voters were
investigated the voters were found alive
and well
a handful
died after legally voting absentee and
then they died by election day or by the
day that the investigation was done
there was some junior senior confusion
it's it's been investigated
massive dumps as donald trump uh uh
likes to say you know about that big
massive dumps yeah big massive dumps of
voting votes in boxes uh being brought
in overnight it's been looked at it's
been widely debunked
all of these claims have actually been
refuted and so donald trump just lying
there trump then posting to truth social
the unselect committee refused to debate
the election results the reason for the
massive crowd on january 6 because they
can't and again
they are in the position
of wanting something unreasonable
we have election results election
results are not something we debate we
don't say hey you know what um
we i believe that a flat tax is best for
the economy and you believe a
progressive tax is best for the economy
let's debate it and each bring forward
our perspectives and historical evidence
no no no we
we counted the ballots and joe biden won
when there have been audits or recounts
done
joe biden won that's it it's there's no
there's nothing to debate as far as that
goes then donald trump posting the
unselects are going against me because i
am the only one who can fix our
endangered country
and they want to destroy it people want
to go back to where we were just two
years ago
again the weaponized narcissism only i
can fix it all of the things trump told
us he would fix during his presidency he
did not fix
and then trump also attacking william
barr william barr who by the way still
said he would vote for trump over a
democrat in 2024 for all of the
criticism that barr has levied against
trump he still said oh i'm not going to
vote for a democrat if it's trump versus
a democrat in 2024 i'll vote for trump
even though
he said that trump is furious with barr
because barr said yeah all of these
claims are bs and trump posting quote
former attorney generally bill barr
a rhino
if there ever was one a rhino named mitt
romney
yeah a rhino means republican and name
only um he didn't have the stamina or
courage to go after vote fraud
was afraid he was going to be impeached
no guts no glory so trump turning on
william barr as well really losing it
now these things trump definitely did
right what we're going to look at next i
don't believe trump wrote
um
yesterday or late the day before
a 12-page letter was released to the
media supposedly written by donald trump
weighing in on the trump riot committee
hearings now i don't believe for a
second that donald trump really wrote a
12-page letter trump doesn't write and
trump doesn't read all he's capable of
as far as we've seen
is um tweet style messages often with
strange grammar spelling and syntax so i
don't believe trump wrote a 12-page
letter but i do believe that trump sat
somewhere and told someone what to write
and chris saliza from cnn received the
letter and gave us a list of the
wackiest things
and uh here are some some key key
moments from this statement that shows
us how the right is thinking of these
hearings number one if they had any real
evidence they'd hold real hearings with
equal representation remember
republicans opted out of that there was
a framework for an actual bipartisan
committee ten members five republicans
five democrats democratic chair
republican vice chair and both the chair
and vice chair have to agree on every
subpoena republicans rejected it so
democrats did what they could which is
they've got liz cheney and adam
kinzinger on the panel so that that's
their fault two they used the illegally
constituted committee to put on a smoke
and mirrors show for the american people
in a pitiful last-ditch effort to
deceive the american public again
there's nothing illegal about the
committee just nothing we've had other
committees the benghazi one we've had
others perfectly legal number three
they've refused to allow their political
opponents to participate in the process
they've excluded exculpatory witnesses
and anyone who so easily points out the
flaws in their story again as chris
eliza writes republicans
crushed the actual bipartisan committee
that they wanted to do
that it is because of republicans that
they um don't have more republicans on
the committee and also
a whole bunch of the pro-trump people
that were subpoenaed didn't go and
that's now the subject of legislation
that includes steve bannon and peter
nabar navarro
four the unselect pseudo committee has
coordinated with their media puppets to
broadcast their witnesses on tv without
opposition cross-examination or rebuttal
evidence again
more than a thousand depositions were
taken of all sorts of witnesses it is
untrue that that is what was done
uh and then a whole bunch of other just
repetition of lies i won't look at all
of these but number seven is they
illegally inflated voter rules that's
unproven they illegally allowed
harvested and stuffed ballots no
evidence of that they abused the use of
mail-in ballots that's there's no
evidence of that they physically removed
republicans from counting facilities
that that's untrue now there are random
republicans who showed up demanding to
oversee the election who were not
allowed to because there's a process for
establishing observers there there were
republican and democratic observers
there were people who just showed up
demanding access it's sort of like if i
go you know
if i go to a court and i say i want to
sit uh alongside the judge
they would say well no you're you
haven't been selected you're not the
judge in the same way if i'm not
actually an election observer i don't
have a right to just show up and uh be
given power there but there is no
evidence for any of those claims
um and a whole bunch of other stuff that
doesn't really have any meaning like
donald trump writing in this letter on
election night america watched as my
lead grew and grew over biden as i was
set to claim another victory we expected
the red mirage we expected that the
early vote would favor trump and that as
the cities were counted overnight and
into the next day it would start to
point more in the direction of joe biden
all of these things we expected so
i don't believe trump wrote this but i
do believe he had input and it really
shows us that they aren't changing their
talking points
every day that passes we have more of an
empirical basis to reject their claims
but they continue making the exact same
claims day after day after day now at
the end of the day
i don't know that these hearings are
really going to have any impact they're
getting an okay audience my guess is the
people watching are mostly the people
who already don't believe the things
that donald trump has been saying so
whether these hearings will have any
impact whatsoever remains to be seen but
the
the lies that they are telling continue
to be the exact same lies and at this
point i don't know who's falling for
them we'll have more on this on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show we'll be back right after
this short break
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show so i mentioned this yesterday in
passing but i want to talk about it a
little bit more because it is really um
a fascinating story
uh we are now learning something that i
knew and if you watch this show you also
knew
about the fundraising that was done in
the aftermath of the 2020 election by
the trump campaign and the republican
party supposedly to fight for the true
results and to fund audits and to fund
recounts and all these different things
we all knew it was a scam and the last i
checked in with you about it about 70 or
75 million dollars had been donated by
just random people who many of whom
don't really have the money to be
donating although some millionaires
donated as well to donald trump
and we knew that it was a scam if you
looked at the fine print you actually
could see that in some cases 50 cents on
every dollar or even more
were earmarked to pay off trump campaign
debt but it's way worse than that one of
the things we learned from the committee
hearings the january 6 trump riot
committee hearing on monday was that the
entire 250 million dollar official trump
election integrity fund or whatever they
called it it was a complete and total
grift scam used in many cases to pay
outrageous speaking fees and salaries to
trump's friends and family that's the
bottom line and i know it's sort of like
well of course i mean look at what
happened with trump university look at
all the different scams that donald
trump has run of course it was a scam
but it wasn't obvious to the people who
needed to hear it the most the trumpist
so let's dig into that a little bit more
zoe lofgren congresswoman zoe lofgren a
democrat who's on the january 6
committee she was interviewed by jake
tapper and they talked about this and
they specifically talk about donald
trump jr's then girlfriend i believe now
fiance kimberly guilfoyle check this out
you showed
people deceived talking about why they
were there on january 6. well people
were conned by the former president
they were conned into believing that the
election had been stolen
and that they should go to the capitol
as the president asked them to they were
conned out i think the average donation
from those email false email requests
was something like 17
these were people who weren't rich
people right they were they were
conned by the president it was a big lie
and it was also a big ripoff and you say
you were just asked i think by manu raju
if the committee has found evidence that
trump and his family quote personally
benefited personally benefited from
donations and you said
yes that's a serious allegation do you
have more details is that a crime
i don't know
you know we're a legislative committee
so that's that's for somebody else to
decide
but for example we know that
um
guilfoyle
was paid
for the introduction she gave at the
speech i mean on january 6 you received
compensation for that
but is that a is that a crime i'm not
saying it's a crime but i think it's a
gift it's a gift because you're you're
telling trump people trump supporters
out there in the hinterlands keep give
us money to to
to
go to court to defend
this election when in fact and then
instead kim guilfoyle who's donald trump
jr's fiance gets paid money for 60 60
000
for two two and a half minutes
you had
money going to
mark meadows foundation into another
foundation you hired the trump
supporters who'd lost their jobs so it
wasn't what he said to his donors this
is to defend
the election it was an entirely
different purpose okay so you get the
point
what a teacher makes in a year
hopefully after having years of
experience in education many teachers
don't make this okay kimberly gilfoyle
the fiancee of donald trump jr makes for
a two and a half minute speech on the
day january 6 paid for by paid for by
the people who mostly don't make
sixty thousand dollars a year she gets
it for two and a half minutes imagine
giving
in some cases your social security check
to a billionaire
supposedly to fund lawyers who are
trying to sort out the election for us
and then it actually goes 400 a second
to his son's future wife
okay and what's amazing is how they are
such transparent grifters but people
fall for it anyway now i know that some
of you say
screw
screw and
yeah to some degree okay i mean they
they a fool and their money are soon
parted if you believe after trump did
all the other scams uh we're gonna build
a wall that mexico is gonna pay for but
they some of them fell for that
obviously it wasn't gonna happen
we're gonna replace obamacare with
something beautiful never even got a
proposal all the if they still fall for
it then they deserve it sure that's fine
and it's less about the individual but
it is a reminder that these are not
people the entire political constituency
of trump are people he mostly hates
trump as a rich new york city guy has
spent most of his life trying to stay
isolated and insulated from the very
people who he cons out of money and once
they're no longer useful trump throws
them out like uh like his dirty diapers
for lack of a better term
um
and the criminality question is a
different one is it is it arguably
fraudulent yes it's arguably fraudulent
but like zoe lofgren says they are a
legislative committee they are not uh
law enforcement and that's going to have
to be looked at aaron rupar had a really
really good piece about this actually um
in which he
outlines
some of the different um
uh payments that were made and we're
going to link to that and you can check
that out but absolutely outrageous stuff
hey i have to tell you i know that uh we
don't we don't typically prefer to take
pleasure
in others misfortune
but when it comes to newsmax i'm taking
pleasure newsmax the radical right-wing
media network has had a big shake-up in
terms of their on-air talent as reported
by radar online greg kelly and sean
spicer have been sidelined at newsmax
and one of the things newsmax has done
is they brought in former fox news host
greta van susteren greta van susteren
had her first episode of the show
yesterday it was a technical disaster
that is delightful to me oh but david oh
sir you're making fun of people that is
a freaking predator right now no no no
no no no
this is disastrous for america
the fact that newsmax has an audience
i'm not saying shut them down i'm not
saying violate their ability let them do
whatever they want but i want them to
fail
and the technical hilarity that took
place yesterday greta van susteren tried
interviewing chuck grassley the
republican senator and it just wasn't
working tech disaster after disaster and
i love it i love every second of it i
admit it for more ranking member of the
senate judiciary committee iowa senator
chuck grassley joins us good evening
senator and it has gotten absolutely
intolerable for the american people
these prices gas food everything's going
straight up what can both parties do
together what is the willingness of both
parties to do together that we can
rescue our economy
you'll have to come through clearer than
you have so far i i couldn't make out
what you're saying
i'm at i'm asking you sir that people
are suffering so much from gas prices
food prices what can republicans and
democrats what are they willing to do
together and what can they do together
to help the economy
okay
i'm sorry it's so
muffled with it sounds like you're
talking in a cave
it sounds like my callers can't hear
anything you've got to
ask me and
and i and i totally understand that
senator but this is our first night on
aaron as you can imagine we have some
apparently some gremlins in the system
um
trying to get the question off to you so
let me ask you a question sort of just
generally sir is um he probably can hear
general questions better than specific
ones so this is a smart strategy
do you have any sort of thought
on food prices
i know you're from a farm state
if you if you're still trying to
interview me
i can't uh make out what you're saying
all right senator thank you very much
and uh we'll give up a little bit wow
what an explosive interview
am i a bad person because i love that i
mean is it if i i'll i'll take the hit
if i'm just a bad person because the
show went completely off the rails i
will accept that but i absolutely love
that um okay so that big shake up at
newsmax but
no shortage of insanity at newsmax where
the guests could hear the interviewer
let's talk about that next um there's a
guy who is a host on newsmax his name is
chris salcedo when he had a radio show i
appeared on chris salcedo's show it was
completely bonkers we
we just talked past each other it made
no the interview made no sense chris
salcedo now has a show on newsmax and
chris salcedo floats the absolutely
insane conspiracy theory
that nancy pelosi wants brett kavanaugh
to be assassinated so that joe biden
will get another supreme court pick and
this was said during an interview with
illinois republican congressman rodney
davis rodney davis doesn't even say
chris that's crazy that's absolutely
insane nancy pelosi wants assassinations
now this all relates to
an incident that took place with supreme
court justice brett kavanaugh where an
armed man
was i guess picked up by police
a block or two away from brett
kavanaugh's house and he he was there
because he was angry with brett
kavanaugh and chris salcedo says you
know this might be a plan to actually
kill kavanaugh in which pelosi is
involved take a look at this the height
of irresponsibility you know a lot of
folks are starting to ask some questions
out there congressman they're openly
wondering why nancy pelosi sat on a bill
that was passed by the senate to protect
supreme court justices
now she's moving after an assassination
attempt on justice kavanaugh are
americans right to question if pelosi
was actually hoping for or encouraging
violence that could lead to joe biden
appointing a new supreme court justice
well it's certainly questions that nancy
pelosi and others need to answer pelosi
needs to answer are you trying to kill a
supreme court justice so that joe biden
will get a pic she must answer that
question it's imperative why she thought
somehow justice kavanaugh after having
an assassin in his backyard is somehow
safe over the weekend we could have
gotten to this bill last week by the way
i don't know that the guy was in the
backyard not that it matters but but she
chose to hold it up and she needs to
answer as to why i mean it was five
years ago that this left-wing gunman
inspired by rhetoric like republican
policies are killing people tried to
kill me and my friends by the way then
they show pictures of his house which is
which is really something else
so uh this is an outrageous uh
conspiracy theory and by the way many of
these people celebrated when ruth bader
ginsburg died under understand that and
speaking of which you know how i've said
before
allegations are often confessions like
with the whole election fraud voter
fraud thing leading up to the 2020
election what they were really saying
was we're going to try to steal the
election they were saying democrats are
planning to steal it what in reality was
is we we they are planning to steal it
should it be looked at as to whether
ruth bader ginsburg really just
genuinely died of disease now of course
i'm being tongue-in-cheek i'm being
facetious but if they all of a sudden
are so focused on pelosi's trying to
kill kavanaugh
maybe it's an another one of these
thinly veiled confessions and one of the
things that is important here
first of all the absurdity of i mean uh
kavanaugh has armed security
and all these different things kind of
weird that pelosi is going to try to
kill him by sending
you know some
deranged gunman uh to to his backyard
when there's all this protection that
doesn't really make sense but beyond
that
violent conspiracies
are not only often projection
but they are very common in this
they're common in fascism they're common
in authoritarianism where you have to
constantly talk about
these um
violent threats
which are then used to justify more
authoritarianism and i don't even think
chris salcedo's conspiracy theory is so
well is well put together enough to
really fall under that but they are a
common sort of feature that uh we often
see we'll have this clip along with
others that we've played
uh on our facebook page which you can
find at facebook.com
slash david pakman show
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
i sadly am going to play for you today
some of the scariest audio and video
that we've had on the show for for a
while
we have seen people show up at
school boards or
city council meetings recently and call
for the killing of gay people of lgbt
people
today i'm going to play for you a clip
of a candidate calling for the killing
of the parents of lgbt kids
this is candidate mark burns it might
not shock you
that mark burns is a trumpist he loves
trump he's pro-trump
he is running in the fourth district in
south carolina
and
he
called for the arrest and execution
of those who advocate for lgbt rights
and the protection of trans children
this was during an appearance on the stu
peters show
and he talked about um
that he is committed to voting for
transphobic laws which will target lgbt
kids and their parents
and then he went further than saying he
will just vote for the legislation
he says he wants those parents held for
child abuse
and put to death if they are convicted
take a look at this this this is
extraordinarily dangerous the lgbt
transgender grooming our children's
minds is a national security threat now
by the way i hate to already interrupt
they you when republicans and
right-wingers get a new shiny toy in
this case it's the word grooming they
use it all the time
grooming has a very specific meaning uh
in the context of child abuse
and um
you know
saying to your kids i love you no matter
who you are it's not really grooming
it's actually not at all grooming but
they're just using the word they're on
the word because it is ultimately
designed to destabilize the republic we
call the united states of america that's
why when i'm elected i don't want to
just vote i want to start holding people
accountable for treason to the
constitution i am going to push to
reenact who act huac is the house of on
american activities committee it was a
real committee that was formulated back
in the 50s and it's a committee that we
should reenact that starts holding these
people accountable for treason we need
to hold people for treason start having
some public hearings and start executing
people who are found guilty for their
treasonous acts against the constitution
of the united states of america do you
understand how insane that is
huac so first of all
i mean it putting to death the parents
of lgbt kids it's
dangerously off the rails but there's
another aspect to this when we talk
about huak the house committee on
un-american activities
we're talking about mccarthyism we're
talking about a committee that looks at
whether americans have been disloyal
don't have to have committed any crime
it's just a do you think the wrong
things which we have tagged
as being a lack of loyalty to the united
states
extraordinarily
dangerous candidate now does this guy
have a shot at winning well
we'll have to wait and see
would it be a shock to me
if this guy actually ended up getting
arrested for you know domestic violence
child porn whatever i'm not saying i
have any evidence of that but no often
times the the loudest people who say
let me one-up even you it's not enough
just to say i'm going to vote
i will demand the killing
sometimes when people go overboard like
that
it's because they have things to hide we
don't know that to be the case with this
guy but that's something that we've seen
but we seem to live in a world where
people can freely express their desire
for large swaths of people to be killed
now i get it he's not personally
threatening to kill anybody
this is not the type of thing where you
would say well you know we're from the
police and we need to talk to you
but
the reaction is well yeah i mean just if
you don't like that don't vote for him
as if this counts as anything even
remotely approximating valid political
discourse uh i i i it's
it's a it's it's increasingly dangerous
not only that people are saying these
things but they they aren't instantly
disqualifying and we go back to 2016
2015 trump and the access hollywood tape
in the entire thing
at a certain point in american political
history
the access hollywood grab them by the
you-know-what tape would have been a
disqualifier that would have been it
just no you you're done you resign
immediately and that's it it's over
and there is almost nothing that they
can't try to explain away at this point
in time now this guy is pro-trump trump
hasn't endorsed him so it's not a
situation where trump would pull his
endorsement or anything like that but
it's considered just like oh yeah well
no i'm against killing the people the
parents of lgbt kids so i'm not going to
vote for him this should be immediately
disqualifying and it's not in modern
american politics hey this is a truly
bizarre story
remember this guy milo yiannopoulos milo
yiannopoulos was this gay british
provocateur who got very involved in
american politics he was a darling of
the right and he would say horrible
things and then he had a sort of uh it
was it's not so much a falling out he
had i guess we'd call it a pr problem
because
he uh was in an interviewed in a show
and i want to be careful with the
language i use here
where he
sort of said it's kind of okay
when there are relationships between
he he wasn't saying prepubescent kids
but he was i i believe talking about
like
sort of like 12 and 13 year olds
and adult
men it was very very strange and he
quickly was dropped by the right-wing
establishment they no longer he was no
longer useful to them and he's made a
couple of attempts at comebacks one of
the things he did is he became
heterosexual now i know that when i say
that you might be wondering well did he
really become heterosexual was he never
actually gay is it what what i i don't
know i'm just telling you he says he is
now heterosexual and um i i don't even
have an interest in commenting on
whether that's a real thing but he he
claims that he is now heterosexual and
this has allowed him to some degree to
at least attempt to re enter the
mainstream american political milieu
he now reportedly is marjorie taylor
green's unpaid intern this is just
bizarre it's it's wacky the washington
post reporting
milo yiannopoulos far-right provocateur
is a marjorie taylor green intern
former breitbart editor is summer intern
for marjorie taylor green he announced
that he had finally been persuaded out
of retirement
saying he was hired for an unpaid
internship with a friend
he attached a photo of a congressional
intern id badge on top of a louis
vuitton bag showing he's an intern in
marjory taylor green's office he her
office didn't explain what his duties
are
but she said so i have an intern that
was raped by a priest as a young teen
was gay has offended everyone at some
point turned his life back to jesus and
church and changed his life great story
great story
the statement was sent after the
washington post article published it
also suggested the media should
interview a colleague of hers about her
trans daughter
greene named the colleague using
transphobic language so it's a
completely bizarre story but it's not
only that milo appears to be an unpaid
intern of marjory taylor green marjory
taylor green also now has a very strange
podcast
and he's off camera but he sort of seems
to be like a sidekick here this this is
one of the strangest stories i've seen
here is just 30 seconds of marjorie
taylor green's recent podcast episode i
believe this is from yesterday and you
hear milo off camera um uh sort of her
her sidekick i guess listen to this tell
us more give us give us a give it tell
us about california well california has
advanced a bill to become a transgender
sanctuary it was introduced by democrat
senator scott weiner why are they always
called weiner why are they always called
weiner anthony weiner scott weiner they
all do all the weiner i don't think they
all go together
now that milo is heterosexual he can do
that type of thing i guess this is a new
form of comedy for milo now that he's
newly heterosexual they kind of some of
them are wanting to get rid of the
wieners i mean this is like like the
whole weenie chop thing can you imagine
being a mother wanting to do that to
your
child
i can't comprehend it i'm sorry i'm
making jokes but it's not funny yeah now
transphobia actually isn't new to milo
and there is a contingent
um there's a transphobic contingent of
the gay community this is just a thing
that exists it's not uh i'm not
personally attacking anyone there there
is
um you might have heard of
trans-exclusionary radical feminism
called turf t-e-r-f there's also a
contingent of the gay community that is
not big on uh that that's not big on
trans that when milo was gay
and again i'm using
the language that he uses when milo used
to be gay he also uh was was transphobic
and in fact when i interviewed milo
years ago on the show
one of the things if i recall correctly
that we talked about and i don't know
who brought it up
were his views on uh feminism i'm sorry
we know his news on feminism where his
views on transfo on transgender uh and
uh it exposed his transphobia so just
all very strange and i don't know what
the next step is like what is what's
interning for marjorie taylor green
where is that a jumping off point two
and i guess we can only wait and see if
it's just a summer internship by the way
milo's i think he's almost 40. uh
i don't know
you know
it's all very strange but there it is
you now know everything that i know we
have a voicemail number and that number
is two one nine
two
david p
here's a caller
not thrilled with my alex jones
impression listen to this
mr pac-man yes sir
if i might offer a criticism of your
show it's that your alex jones
impersonation
needs a lot of work okay see what you
want to do when you're doing an alex
jones impersonation you want to make it
sound like you've just smoked every
cigarette
but you wouldn't know anything about
that you demon rat
uh no in all seriousness
i do enjoy the show uh thank you for
your interviewing acumen uh in general
and i was curious if you
uh agree that in part
the rise of trumpism or fascism whatever
it is you want to call it
uh there's some responsibility
of
the people on the left
who
[Music]
perhaps
are performative in their outrage when
something
you know
messed up happens
um because it just kind of seems like
there's a whole
wing of supporting trump that deals with
i just want to trigger the libs
yeah listen
there i i'm not doing a both sides thing
but there is some performative outrage
on both sides it's over very different
things and it's tailored and and sort of
focused differently
but i've seen performative outrage on
the left as well and i i don't
participate in it and um i don't even
know that i care to get into the
specifics right now but there's
performative outrage all over now as far
as the alex jones impression is it that
bad globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
i don't know i think it's okay i i
generally don't think my impressions are
very good i also do susan collins
well i was very disappointed to see that
donald trump killed a man but i think
that he's learned his lesson
and i am not in favor of moving forward
with any consequences whatsoever
um what other ones do i do i don't know
my impressions are all like a four out
of ten
i think uh they're they're bad but i
think at least it's passable who i'm
referring to
um
yeah okay anyway let's uh let's move on
on today's bonus show
there is a florida abortion ban
this is fascinating because it's the
opposite of how these things usually
work
there are jewish groups now saying the
florida abortion ban violates the
religious freedom of jewish folks this
is this is absolutely brilliant
there are jewish religious teachings
which say in certain cases you should
have an abortion you should have an
abortion
and
the way that the florida abortion ban is
written would violate the religious
freedom of those jewish folks
to access that abortion and we're going
to talk about that on today's bonus show
secondly
do you remember when um
alexander litvinenko was poisoned by a
russian agent this was a major story um
a few years ago i believe it was
polonium um
the agent linked to the poisoning of
litvinenko has now died
from covid which is a bizarre turn of
events
and then lastly
russia has a rebranded mcdonald's it's
sort of like a mcdonald's clone because
of mcdonald's closing in russia
it's called delicious that's all
we will talk about whether producer pat
can get vegan treats at the new
mcdonald's clone
and we will talk about so many other
things
don't miss today's bonus show i will be
on it pat will join me you can sign up
at
joinpackman.com remember alex jones is
still against you signing up oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad he still thinks it's
predatory that is a freaking predator
right there right i love the bonus show
quite frankly sign up at joinpacman.com
coupon code big voting 22 for a discount
i will see you then or otherwise back
here tomorrow